petite info médias dont je vous le dis
je vous donnerai deux candidats qui ont
été validées par la production de danse
avec les stars j'en ai un premier je
vous dis je vous donnerai le deuxième
tout à l'heure et le deuxième aussi vous
donnerez votre avis alors je vous le dis
le premier c'est quelqu'un que malick
connais très bien
ouais même très très bien ce premiers
candidats de danse avec les stars qui
aurait été validé par la production dont
qu'ils attendent sa réponse
c'est quelqu'un qui danse très bien
c'est un garçon qu'on aime beaucoup et
déjà des lycéens comédien oui allez
essayer de trouver un comédien
oui tourné avec malik oui franck franck
en restant dans le gast en ville non il
était d'en parler il était dans pattaya
and one c'est très très bien reuters
très très bien noir silence très bien et
anouar voilà devrait faire partie il en
veut tu du casting de danse avec les
stars il a très envie eux aussi donc a
priori lui c'est fait ça match comme on
dit ça m'a montré que c'est une très
bonne idée oui parce que anwar et qui
s'annonce télécom en août madame envie
de le faire vivaki fais ça tu es voilà
moi je vous dis il va être excellent je
pense que vous allez l'adorer au plus
cinq garçons gains avec succès une danse
donald déjà il est déjà en train de dire
réfléchir il centra d'un petit peu il
est très bon et c'est un mec en or ça a
été tout de suite il y à une personne
qui a été contacté par la production de
tf1
ils ont fait même un entretien ils la
veulent absolument
voilà dans l'émission je vous le dis
elle a dit que pour l'instant elle
allait réfléchir parce qu'elle a
beaucoup de choses à côté
sachez qu'ils veulent absolument mokhtar
ils veulent absolument
enora malagré nora et n'aura donc notre
pote enora et nohra
renora dans danse avec les stars moi je
vous dis la vérité pour eux je pense que
c'est génial pour elle après c'est elle
qui décidera parce qu'elle a beaucoup de
choses là elle va faire une très grosse
pièce à la rentrée voilà avec une mise
en scène il alain s'axent donc c'est du
très lourd
les chiffres voilà enora dans danse avec
les stars est ce que vous aimez ou est
ce que vous aimez pas et je vous donnais
à près de 3 info voilà concernant cette
affaire vous aimez tous
oui voilà c'est une super idée non mais
sait-il série des cons à moudre dans wii
est ce que c'est une bonne idée pour et
noires pensées droit oui parce que les
mecs énorme si jamais se fait éliminer
au premier coup la sacra c'est ça parce
qu'elle pense qu'elle va être dans les
deux trois premiers au niveau de la
danseuse de ouf et n'aura quoi voter ne
t'aime pas toi il aura dans danse avec
les stars d'ivoire non parce qu'elle n'a
pas fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'amour tu apparais sans rigoler quoi
[ __ ] ou alors vous n'aimez pas bah non
j'aime pas trop pour et n'aura pas ce
qu'elle a toujours dit qu'elle voulait
faire l'émission et je pense qu'on à
macaye qu'elles le fassent très bien
mais je trouve que les chantiers sont
gérés sont toujours pas sur les voies de
garage mais un peu quand même un peu se
dévoile si l'afrique veut pas dire mais
je voyais avec project est dans le feu
de l'action et en même temps faire danse
avec les stars je trouve ça un peu oui
vous gérez dit et comme elle danse très
bien mais forcément il sera là le gars
qui s en sortir les tribunes jamais la
surface et l'émission de télé ça pour
donner sa famille avec thank you girl
elle va faire le show et laval et le
rire elle valmasque usa est énorme dans
une véritable aubaine pour pas
d'examiner la danse avec les stars
surtout elle va susciter le crois
qu'avec autant je suis convaincu qu'avec
l'aval ceni avec la roumanie ou la wii 2
tout dépend ce que l'on veut faire après
si elle a fait un choix artistique
différente de ce qu'elle faisait avant
moi donc c'est une bonne idée
maintenant s'il veut rester dans les
médias n'évoquent manar débit non mais
j'ai en tout cas est ce qu'on peut dire
entre nous c'est que tf1 une fois de
plus ils ont une imagination
camille combal à la présentation
matthieu delormeau candidats et nora les
gars on peut tous venir aujourd'hui
carrément piqué encore un génie sans
décoller c'est pas la peine d'avoir à on
va partager les cerveaux puisque tu fais
tout ce que je fais merci oui non ceux
qui font ça c'est qu'ils ont le temps
parce que c'est tous les jours les
répétitions
donc c'est des gens qui travaillent pas
beaucoup en revanche c'est pourquoi car
ils peuvent alors qu'apple a en revanche
ils peuvent négocier d'autres choses en
général et des fins ils leur promettent
toujours autre chose derrière leur
promettre des trucs ouaki saison après
j'ai merdé
electrostar ya plus tard dans danse avec
les stars donc elle va détonner quoi
vous me range cancale et qu'elle est à
sa place après effectivement je
comprends la réserve qui est relative au
timing le fait qu'elle est effectivement
près cette orientation vers le théâtre
mais je pense que c'est une excellente
candidate pour tf1 en tout cas c'est un
super choix maxime plus elle a des
facultés artistique un bon tremplin vu
par plus de 5 millions de spectateurs
les enchaînant cinq millions c'est égal
en temps
en se disant ouais j'ai deux autres non
si vous aimez coeur quand c'est quel
conseil lui donne moi france me concerne
ça qui m'intéressait enora choix le
faire j'ai tout le temps des bonnes je
jeu l'adorent franchement et nous va pas
faire cette émission à la wii car elle
était trop d'être au dessus pour faire
cette émission machines adaptées en
train de faire du théâtre là t'es tu vas
faire un truc énorme au théâtre il est
retourné vraiment en arrière dans sec
les stars ma chérie je te dis la vérité
j'ai rien contre ces démissions mais
cette émission elle est sur la fin c'est
l'émission mois alors qu'elle tard l
affaire alors que toi tu es bien vivante
était en train de cartonner ton étoile à
ce que tu fais sur le net ça cartonne ta
pièce de théâtre c'est un gros truc car
rien à [ __ ] là bas à quoi si tu
l'avais fait il ya deux trois ans ça
aurait été énorme là tu vas sur une
émission où ils savent plus quoi faire
il appelle tout le monde même ma mère
ils vont l'appeler rien à faire là bas
voilà que des tris tarbes pau n'a rien à
faire là bas voilà c'est cool pour un
noir
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
dans ce bassin danseurs sait pas elle
adore danser
elle adore danser les shows métissé
comédienne et animatrice à l'icm arrivée
sur l'île a dit un noir non à nous
éditeurs pensent que si la france était
un peu plus ouvert d'esprit on pourrait
la laisser et qui fait elle pourrait
faire ce qu'elle veut après le problème
c'est qu'ici on peut pas faire plusieurs
choses à la fois parce que tout de suite
nous met dans des cases well à présent
vous le feriez vous oui mais si tu
penses que ça peut nuire et noir moi je
pense qu'à l'heure du talent et que même
si elle le fait le bas-congo
je pense que là là aujourd'hui ali ont
râlé ali là et c'est faire un truc qui
est là voilà je vous dis la vérité
si ron quand même un voit maintenant
attendez il aura aujourd'hui elle est
très très populaire je suis nommé hall
et répétez le rapport à la forte plus
haddad danse avec les stars de danse
avec les stars ne va lui apporter qu'est
ce que va apporter une aura danse avec
les stars bah dites moi banane édition
de l'argent oui mais de l'argent
d'importants l'argent c'est bah si vous
pensez qu'à s'acquitter de cette
émission
non mais non mais non mais franchement
qu'est ce que ça va lui rapporter les
droits humains des primaires mais non
mais pour son animal la poussière sony
m'a rapporté que qui vont leur permettre
des fils après l'édition gagner la
compétition comme comme avant ce qu'ont
avancé vous ne devrez les deux autres
noms à l'escaut bond de 56%
bon ben si moi je trouve que c'est super
beau
j'honore moi ce que je parle parce que
je la dore juste rappelé au banc c'est
une très mauvaise idée pour elle parce
que je parle avec au coeur que j'adore
et non alors qu'ils sont les deux autres
noms lisandro gucci le gagnera bien
gabriel de kenzo lighted et vincent
moscato même ah ouais ouais non vincent
il est super mais c'est vrai que voilà
ça non mais c'est plus sur nos goûts de
chiens qu'est ce qu'elle est c'est déjà
gagné deux attentats il est super league
où ils sont tous super moi c'est pas un
casting de stars mais franchement tout
ce qu'on entend là